[Applause]
but why is every day january 6. why why
does the calendar say january 6th every
single day
because on that day apparently he asked
for his vice president to be murdered
now how do you spin that that's that's
those are reports i've seen that people
were saying that and if people were
threatening the life of the vice
president i'm sure there are great
federal laws against that let's use them
but trump gave that speech on the south
lawn where he said all those awful
things about mike pence and urged that
raucous crowd
what did he say he said fight like hell
yeah right he it was entirely
foreseeable that that that that crowd
was going to behave in a violent manner
right like that that's why you have
republican members of congress when the
guys are taking the fields that's why
you have republican members of congress
asking what we're going to do to about
these people who might come in and try
to do something violent to us debbie
lesko a conservative congresswoman from
from arizona was very concerned about
that and that's part of that's part of
what's made the investigation feel a
little bit absurd at certain places
because this happened right in front of
us we saw trump do this on television on
january 6th and so it's like yeah now we
have these reports that he said that he
wanted mike pence that it was cool with
him if they hang mike pence but he took
these actions that clearly put the vice
president in physical danger after
spending days okay but let me ask the
president to break the law practical
question this is a little new that he
said pence deserves it
maybe i read that in reports but i
worked with them for five years straight
i know i'm one of them hold on oh i had
left this testimony of people who were
there then okay
let's say we find what let's say there's
a smoking gun tape like there is with
the
call to the secretary of state of
georgia where he said i need to find 11
000 more votes
i need to find 11 000 more votes is that
something that should prevent this man
from ever running again or
saying he wants to hang his vice
president
should he be able to run again for
president 17 times in the last five
minutes hold on that's what this is
about at least you admit it at least you
said the quiet part out loud that these
investigations are about preventing him
from ever running again
and
they hold on they should just admit that
they should say we have absolutely no
man with a plan in the white house we're
paying five dollars a gallon for
gasoline infant formula is nowhere we're
going to get to that part of it let's
just stay with it happens every single
day to americans so bill it's a real
concern okay it is and we will get to
that part of the show but let's talk
about what we're really talking about
now which is donald trump now he's
talking about donald trump he hasn't
been president in a year and a half
should he be able to run again given
that this also was not
ad hoc this was a planned coup this is
something else that came out this wasn't
an act of passion
a crime of passion this was premeditated
well he had this seven point plan i
think that's why they focused so much in
the hearing on trying to establish that
he knew that he had lost the election
that all of these people had told him
what what you told him that he did not
win this election because
they've in court filings the committee
has already suggested that they have
sufficient evidence that that trump
committed a specific crime that he tried
to obstruct an official proceeding by
trying to get mike pence to act outside
of his constitutional duties and
authorities and declined to count the
electoral votes that would have given
joe biden the win in the election they
say that the department of justice could
charge him for that um and so that you
know that that case i don't know that
it's the most important thing for the
public whether trump knew that he had
lost or not but that's important for
establishing the crime in order to show
that he that he acted corruptly he has
to have known that he was not entitled
to the win that he was seeking to obtain
through the vice president failing to
count all of the electoral votes so that
would be the thing that doj could charge
around if they were going to bring
criminal charges right but only if he
believes that he lost
well
you